let's go to the next one you not always
have been threatened in that my head is
going to come off at any minute right my
parents grew up and lived there they
didn't die but once
the civil war broke out then it became
lethally dangerous to be Jewish I mean
we were going to be executed we left so
you never know when we're going to go
from tolerating you - off with the heads
and that's been the history for the past
fourteen hundred years
so pretty much he's time up we just
never know when they're gonna flip we
can translate it it like that right what
you gotta say so there's two things of
this really important things that ought
to be really stressed one is that now
he's making it as if Muslims are
intrinsically violent and that you don't
know when they are going to actually
become violent the question is why would
that be your assumption of only Muslims
mostly there are segments of Muslims
we're not denying that there are some
Muslims that are prone to violence that
have been violent that continued to be
violent but is that an exclusively
Muslim problem that's point one number
two is where is once again your claim is
noticeable by its lack of evidence so in
other words in order to make this claim
where's your evidence from the Quran and
Sunnah because once again you're
conflating Islam and Muslims Islam as a
religion there is enough in the religion
to make it patently clear to anyone who
has a sincere mind and a pure heart and
who's receptive to listening to these
arguments that Islam is categorically
against the killing of innocent or let's
not even use the word is it
non-combatant people because we're
innocent kabisa alcohol is subjective
what does the word doesn't mean we are
saying non-combatants what is the
evidence of this a hadith is narrated by
the Prophet Muhammad verses men Catalano
are hidden Lemire aha ahá tell Jenna
whoever kills a noncombatant non-muslim
will never smell the fragrance of heaven
why have our translated as noncombatant
non Muslim because this hadith which is
in Buhari is a hadith authentic has been
narrated upon by Eva Hodja La Scala any
one of the scholars of Islam major
scholars who wrote let her bury one of
the major commentaries probably the best
to have written about the body this is
collection
and the most authoritative book of
Hadees according to Sunni Muslims he
says I'm ahead here in this hadith means
as in me it means a Mahidol most Atman
so in other words any any non-muslim
who is a noncombatant that's the summary
so if the Prophet is telling us that you
you will never smell the fragrance of
paradise if you if you attempt to murder
or if you murder a noncombatant
non-muslim and this man is saying
Muslims are prone to violence and he's
indicating that potentially that
violence comes from the Islamic sources
then does that not run counter to this
particular hadith not regarding of
course the the Quran way says in chapter
60 verse 8 well awesome heart Allah says
lay and her Kamala and in ladina
lemonparty lucuma Dini well I'm usually
do come in the arrow command table aruba
motto [ __ ] to Elaine in Allah helm
opposite in that Allah does not forbid
you of being nice and kind to those
non-believers who do not take you out of
your homes or try and kill you and that
certainly Allah loves those who are just
this particular verse in the Quran is
not abrogated no scholar has said is
abrogated no more festive no exigent
applying the her musical approach has
said that this verse is abrogated
therefore with this verse and this
hadith and of course the many other
verses in the Quran like 532 chapter 5
verse 32 in other verses
it's categorically clear that the
Islamic position is that it is not
allowed it is not allowed for a Muslim
to endanger or kill or murder a
non-muslim who is a noncombatant in any
case this runs counter to this man's
claim now any other verses that I
mentioned in the verbatim would have got
the Quran where we have intact tamper
free tamper proof as we had it revealed
over 1400 years ago we have it and
there's no other book like it yeah there
are references in there and there is
verses that people will take a lot of
times out of context so how do you now
for those skeptic maybe Joe or one of
his followers they said well what about
those verses those verses how do you
read those interpret those verses well
there's two things that need to be
looked at we are not denied well first
of all Muslim position is
pacifistic one and that has to be made
patently clear that Islam is not a
religion of pacifism in other words we
do believe that there is a scope an
international scope from an
international perspective in
international relations perspective for
defensive and sometimes historically
there has been pre-emptive excursions
and that's that's happened there's been
campaigns we're not saying that didn't
happen and we wouldn't deny that that
happened that did happen that is part of
the Islamic corpus there are verses in
the Quran which encourage in the context
of war for aggression there is for
example in chapter 8 verse number 12 and
13 it says so all clear equal Lubell
adeana Cafaro Rama father EMU focal and
happy with the removing homunculi benign
which is very much parented by a lot of
these Islamophobes which says that I
will put in the hearts of the
disbelievers terror so you know chop the
hit them up the next and hit them at the
fingertips what is this talking about
it's very very clear that chapter 8 of
the Quran chapter 9 chapter 4 chapter 2
all those places and those place in the
Quran which talk about violence
reference the context of war no comment
only combat and you know what the
evidence of this is and this is
something which unfortunately and this
management to be an Arab but I don't
think he's familiar with these things I
will challenge anyone actually on this
yeah there is no place in the Quran
where the word where killing is
mentioned where killing is mentioned or
someone who's a non-muslim
without at least the beginning of that
particular segment a reference to he
tell being made now the word patel in
arabic it necessitates fighting from
both sides it has to have fighting from
both sides patel means fighting from
both sides whenever the Quran mentions
fighting or killing it only does so when
it's clear that the one who you're
fighting is a combatant that is
intending to endanger you and endanger
your life and endanger your property not
in the context where that person is a
noncombatant that is clear in the
linguistic what you would call the meter
this is called a meter the arabic meter
of this
Patel it cannot miss her it cannot mean
one person murder one person murdering
another person who is a noncombatant it
necessitates in the Arabic language that
there is fighting from both sides so
everywhere in the Quran which talks
about fighting only does so in the
context of war and this is absolutely
non-controversial considering
considering that that's that is the
foreign policy of almost every if not
every country in the world today it's
absolutely not controversial what
they've made a controversial because
they need to stigmatize the other and
today the other is the Muslim let's go
to the next clip we got it we got quite
a few to go through let's go you ready
for the next one this shirt actually
looks good on Jo doesn't it it does
right it kind of complements his
physique yeah we can get you another one
jo hopefully when we come down when he
invites Muhammad hijab and myself will
come down or or you can write him we get
you someone else that will need you come
what did you come we'll come together
and shout let's go to the next one
you